today's topic boom
that's such a Jamaican and New York
thing all right so boom
New York people don't know it's from
it's just that Jamaicans they [__]
use it at the end of the sentence okay
yeah boom
we talk about yeah
can we go over there so let me go to
take the thing right take the money boom
so what happened all right okay so boom
I'm sorry Jamaican speaking of Jamaicans
bbls uh what what you got to do about
Jamaicans I don't know I thought about
daggering for some reason
there's nothing Sharp don't flat about
that [__] it's just a plywood okay so
BBs
I feel like bbl's now
are here to stay
they're not just here to stay I think in
the near future they're going to be the
new normal in that most women or like a
large majority of them large chunk of
them are gonna have bibios
[Music]
um
it's a possibility I think that
well the theater going to stay or even
going to leave like it's it's
I I think it's not necessarily going to
stay it's not gonna stay because not a
lot of people are
here for the maintain of the BBL the
people a lot of people that get the BBL
or not maintaining that [__] properly
a lot of people so that [__] is dropping
really quick and it's ugly and it's
uneven you understand what I'm saying so
I don't think it's gonna stay and if it
stays it's just going to be a bunch of
uglies walking I mean walking
walking bump yeah I completely disagree
bbls are a game changer for those
watching who have been confused by why
we're using This Acronym BBL is a
Brazilian butt lift especially when
girls get their ass stuck yeah but
here's what's crazy about this what's
crazy about it unlike the breast job
they do not put something foreign
they're taking fat they're transplanting
it but you guys ready this is the really
crazy part if you look at a bunch of
girls Instagrams right now who are
popping right and you look at the ads
you might not be able to tell they have
a bbr the reason why is because you're
looking in the wrong spot you're
supposed to look at their stomach yeah
because the BBL also doubles up as a
form of a tummy tuck or almost like
liposuction midsection what they end up
doing is they're taking a lot of the fat
around the midsection the hips to give
an hourglass shape and they adding just
a tad bit of it to the ass so the ashes
are kind of modest but they're also
getting The Hourglass shape women have
literally reconfigured their body using
like basically editing tools like like
like [__] Tetris okay and they're
getting fat booties looking like pears
and [__] based off of Just A surgery
that transparents in fact even when you
grab a BBL they're well done it don't
even feel bad
yeah I mean like and he wears them too
like you can feel the difference you can
feel the bad huh you can feel the bad
when you grabbing the BBL sometimes you
can't tell
that's why I'm saying they're here to
stay surgery is getting so Advanced that
it's replacing the new normal it's kind
of like cyberpunk 27 27 2077. you got
garbage ass game that world where like
cyber implants or no that's the norm I
think surgery is only going to go
further yes the editing is going to
become more extensive and that's why I'm
saying bbls are here to stay not only
here to stay they're going to be the new
normal because why would you go your
whole life you know what I mean wanting
a certain shape and not getting it when
you can just pay anywhere from six to
ten Grand go get it done
knife and foreign
what's good my people I hope everybody
is doing great I know you like
superheroes superheroes I'm talking to
you about is the low-key wave what is
that oh I'm gonna tell you what that is
that is a prostate massager yeah I know
I said that and you got scared you're
like oh my God I can't massage my
prostate yes you can we need to talk
more about our health man yeah we do we
do not talk about our pleasure let me
tell you how it works
this massage is the inside this massages
are in between both at the same damn
time I got
I got time yep in out and it vibrates
then moves you have your your health and
you have your lady and you want to be
able to pleasure her as well well when
we talk about Loki we got to talk about
Tor what is that that's a ring a what
ring it's a ring that vibrates you put
that
you know where to put that it's not in
it's out it's around
elastic you put it on and then it
vibrates yeah it vibrates to give your
lady all the pleasure that she needs
there's different molds and stuff like
that it feels very good oh you can
increase the power
God damn that thing vibrates like it has
a V8 in it you use that you're gonna be
able to pleasure your lady while
pleasuring yourself as well click on the
link below and you're gonna be able to
prophesate yeah take advantage of uh the
wonderful discount that Lilo has that
thing really nice for him for her for
everybody I think it's just going to
change to something else you know I mean
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
see some people walking on the street
with a robobot and I mean not RoboCop
Robo but
pop pop how can someone carry in the
butt you understand yeah it's gonna come
to that if what I just said was very
stupid and very nerdy but I think it's
not that stupid and that nerdy I think
it's gonna come to that but anyways all
that to say uh for the BBF it's very
dangerous It's Gonna Come less and less
dangerous it's gonna be it if they able
to make that surgery and the technology
for that surgery uh less invasive and
less
um dangerous then yes it's definitely
going to stay but it's that BBL is very
dangerous it's very [__] up it's very
yeah okay
this is how you know it trickles down
every celebrity like like so many of
them have gotten even the ones you
wouldn't expect yeah right there's some
people that you think that are natural
no like rhinoplasty snow surgery super
common now Botox nobody even bats an eye
getting your lips done nobody even cares
no more that's what's gonna happen to be
and then it's gonna go even further from
there one day they're gonna have a whole
surgery you can do to get your eyes
changed the color yeah definitely who
needs natural nobody gives a [__] no
more [__] you could have yellow eyes
that technically you can
with like context no it's a contact that
goes inside the eye
yeah
I think it's kind of new so maybe it's
not mainstream yet but all this to say
the future is looking like that and so
for me on the outside looking in
you know the whole BBF think crazy craze
was interesting
because I was looking at something I
couldn't even tell and then someone just
explained to me like no you're looking
in the wrong spot you gotta look at the
stomach because what ends up happening
is that what these women are doing to
get The Hourglass shape because they're
removing the fat here and then putting
it here but what's weird about it is
they got this hourglass shape and they
got the ab line showing but they got
cellulite around their legs which is
just not possible if you got a low body
fat as a woman where your abs are
showing you shouldn't have tremendous
amount of fat deposits around your legs
but they do because it's unnatural give
me except if you have a condition but
yeah most generally speaking that's not
normal right and so because the practice
is so unnoticed as a woman and it's not
even a critique and I'm gonna get mad
why wouldn't you get one
it makes you way more desirable you pay
what eight to ten Grand have results
depending on where you go yes you can go
to Turkey and get it for cheaper turkey
is more than Dental stuff and the hair
transplants the hair transplant and the
dental stuff is in Turkey but Colombia
Colombia Dominican Republic if you get
the local prices instead of the farm
ones you'd be surprised so all this to
say we put such an emphasis on ladies to
look good and to be very physically
attractive and here you have these
surgeries that are looking more and more
seemingly attractive and also offering
the most ideal body type that most men
like which is The Hourglass shape
because other women who've got bbls who
don't have fat asses you guys are
thinking about the like the dump trunks
or like the [__] diaper look I'm not
talking about that they're super modest
ones that they're getting now that like
people will never know about
but if you don't train that [__] that
[__] sags and drops because added weight
to your butt to your buttocks it's it's
it's gravity is going to do with her
people it's not everybody that's willing
to do the work and that's where you see
drop or botched jobs obviously you're
always gonna see that because people are
not willing to pay the price and see the
proper people does that I think most of
people get it done do the work
yeah because your only thing oh yeah
no it's not that is that the people that
don't do the job that's what you see
exactly that's what you see the ones
that actually do the work you don't see
them or even this
some people get such modest bbls the
work that needs to be done is so minimal
yeah you know I mean like we're thinking
about the horror stories of that but the
[__] got a big ass hole like that ass
is huge the woman I'm talking about you
can barely tell they went from no booty
to having a nice look so
all this to say I I question like if
this is going to be the new one we're
just gonna self-edit where does it end
and I'm actually curious ladies how
would like if bbls are normal or not
everyone's kind of accepting them okay
even guys a lot of them are like fine
with it nowadays because if you look at
polls like a lot of dudes they'll say
they don't like it but the women that
they go after the women that they just
left out of the women that they're even
willing to date they'll still date them
I wonder
if guys are now getting surgeries to
increase their height or increase their
dicks are women gonna be with it I think
they would yeah BDL
Brazilian dick lift
that's a different one but a different
one but but out of different ones yeah
but
and then if editing becomes a new normal
what does that do for people's
self-esteem I wonder
it's no longer work with your flaws or
improve on things it's like you can just
change anything and everything yeah
people are just saying anything that
happened people think that happiness
that they're gonna think they're gonna
change the exterior but they're not
going to change their mental and that's
what happened and that's right there is
a whole ass Mental Health
issue because you changed you went off
to this drama and from like day and
night you become something else day and
night whenever there's a quick change in
your lifestyle there's there's there's
some work to be done mentally whenever
you go to super port or super rich
there's something to to
um to work on with your mental health
when you go from not being noticed and
then having all the attraction the
attention on you there's you there's
some work to be done in which your your
mental love and it's not everybody that
are willing to do the work and I don't
know what the [__] that's gonna happen
in the in the future but it is what it
is it is crazy to think about though no
uh what
that that's going to be the future yeah
well I think it's funny is that
everything that's being done right now
is all things that they were laughing at
us when we were in elementary they were
laughing at girls for having a bad a big
a big booty yeah and now they're having
fat asses they were laughing at
motherfucker's fat being lips yeah you
look like a baboon like they look like a
[__] baboon uh next [__] surgery
is gonna be like a Brazilian nose lift I
don't know make your nostrils bigger I
doubt that one no I had to doubt that
one too but you know it's so funny
yeah it's tough the future is gonna be
an interesting place and I wonder what
you guys think I think most of the
comments are going to be against it and
I think it's easy to like kind of virtue
for that outwardly because I think
everyone wants the whole idea of natural
but I have to ask when everything that
dudes on social media are grasping
towards are shining our whole light on
in terms of like women having huge asses
and big titties and all this other stuff
right I have to wonder how much of it is
just a bunch of virtue stuff and how
much it is real because it seems like
dudes really do be clamoring against
women who are unnatural they don't
really care that much maybe I'm wrong
but most of the big ass Instagrams I see
that women are not natural no definitely
are not natural so already watching
because it's nice when they're watching
because it's a fetish or a freak Show I
don't know I think this people say like
oh no they're just liking them on
Instagram doesn't mean they would
actually date them I don't believe that
one second I think most of those dudes
are out there in those comment sections
saying babe you so hot if they had one
[__] opportunity to sniff that girl's
toilet seat they would lit The Whole
Bowl they would redo her bathroom just
to get in the tubes and sniff out them
farts I believe that yeah I believe that
if you simping that hard in the comments
you wish it for a chance to lick some
toes you want to get that crust in
between each [__] follicle yeah yeah you
trying to get nasty with it this
[__] went graphic I'm just
saying that kind of desperate with you
like damn so [__] I don't know I don't
buy the whole idea that they wouldn't
get with a woman who's on there oh they
would I don't buy that and then comment
sections are full of thirst so I wonder
I wonder what it's like but the future I
think as plastic surgery is now
worldwide and everybody getting them
every everywhere I think it's just going
to go from here and I think we just got
to accept it at some point I said as it
might be
people are going to self-edit
and that's the new normal
yeah you know what it's scary though
what if I start seeing [__] with bbls
I'm like so [__] gay men you haven't
seen that those dudes videos
I can assure you no yeah well no yup
yep there's dudes getting PBS I said
what I said
this is a sickness
yeah those little bbls absolutely